is stargate about to go into
pre-production
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so
if you are a regular site tracker you
will know that i have been talking to
people that work at mgm and they've been
able to tell me a few very interesting
bits of information the last couple of
weeks that i've been spending quite a
lot of effort trying to make certain
word real before i shared them with you
guys because this is actually quite big
news and if true basically means
stargate has gone into pre-production
very early pre-production so what is it
that i've been told well basically
three different sources mgm now have
confirmed to me that storyboards and
concept art is being produced for the
early tv series and a movie as we know
brad wright has produced a script for
the pilot of a stargate series he was
planning to produce four mgm a little
over two years ago now that never got to
the storyboard stage but now a
storyboard for that series has been
commissioned as well as concept art and
a production bible now the production
bible is very interesting because that
basically is a document that would be
shared with writers
that basically tells them the rules of
the stargate universe this is something
they did for the next generation another
star trek series just to give something
as they had different writers come in
episode after episode that they
basically stick to the continuity and
they stick to the rules that's going to
be really important for any future
series if they are planning to stick to
canon
so if sg1 and sgu and sga still exist a
production bible is going to be really
important it's going to tell the new
writers exactly what's come before and
what the rules of the tv show are
basically what the technology is how
things work what they can do and what
they can't do
concept art is also going to be really
important because again according to my
source they have been told they're
allowed to make up to 25 changes
now
this is something we've had in star trek
the enterprise is allowed to be 25
different from the original for the new
series of strange new worlds now a lot
of people have shouted it's because of
copyright it's not because of copyright
it's because
they want to modernize things slightly
they want to make it look a little newer
and a little fresher and inject some new
ideas
now they're going to do that when they
reboot stargate it's not going to look
exactly the same as sg1 there's new
technology they can use to produce a lot
of the
um cgi etc and
there's basically they're just going to
want to freshen up a little bit
but the interesting point is they've
been told they're not allowed for it to
look more than 25 different so basically
they still want to have the feel and the
look of the original series just maybe a
new twist the storyboarding is also very
interesting now brad wright's pilot
never got storyboarded but it is being
produced now
a second series is also apparently in
the works to get storyboarded so there
must be somebody else that has written
the script as alongside brad wright's
but i'm afraid i don't have any more
information on that and and i wouldn't
want to speculate but if somebody has ex
produced a script to go along right
that's been done very much in secret and
i don't even think brad wright knows
also there is a storyboard or at least
an initial storyboard for a movie now
i'm told they do not have a script for
that movie but what they do have is
basically a general plot idea and that
is what's being storyboarded out so it
isn't this isn't something they're going
to be using to actually as part of
pre-production
and which is used a lot storyboards are
used by directors to sort of figure out
shooting sequences and things like this
and they use actually a lot to do with
costing as well they use it they can
break it all they can break the film
down basically and figure out how much
it's going to cost to produce and all
this sort of thing um production
schedules when they need actors here
there and everywhere now i'm being told
that's not what this is being used for
and being told what they're basically
doing is producing storyboards to take
to executives of amazon and mgm to say
this is what we're planning to do this
is what we wanted to look like
what's your feedback
in an attempt to then hopefully get
green lit and they should also be able
to give them a rough budget idea based
on those storyboards and what they think
the production cost might be
but that again is very early
pre-production
so that's basically what i'm being told
is happening right now now i would
actually consider this the first like
solid bit of information that we've had
about a new stargate series actually
being seriously considered by amazon mgm
is still obviously in firm control and
owns the rights to this but obviously
amazon are going to be writing all the
checks for any new production
again i have been told that actually
it's believed in mgm and amazon that
this sale might actually be tied up
within the next two to three months
if that is true
then this seems to be the first step
towards going into proper pre-production
this is them storyboarding now getting
all the ideas straight figuring out
which ideas they want to go with because
there seems to be two competing ideas
for the tv series the brad wright pilot
and something else
as well as getting the executives on
board so they can see where the project
is see where the project is going
probably kick it to death and throw in
all their ideas that will ruin it but
we'll
won't worry about that bridge till we
come to it but then they can actually
either green light it or tell them to go
back to the drawing board put a quick
comment now tell me what do you think do
you think this news about early
pre-production is exciting do you think
it's
real and happening
if it is happening what do you want to
see because they're going to be making
some very big decisions on basically
what is one of our favorite tv shows in
the next few months and
the decisions they make you know are
gonna really strongly affect what we
then see on our screens what are you
hoping they're gonna decide
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out and
for small free you can join the channel
hit that join button underneath and help
me produce more content and become a
fully fledged sidetracker also you can
join us on facebook the link is in the
description as always guys please stay
safe and i'll see you next time